all right welcome everybody this
workshop is gonna be about the
scheduling machine learning pipelines
using Apache airflow so talking about
pipelines I already had some nice
experiences this morning with pipelines
because I was trying to do travel here
by train and it was a gas leakage near
best so I was stuck at the station of
Dumbo's so nice nice intro about these
pipelines so what are we gonna do today
we're gonna start with a little
introduction from ourselves so for me
and from my colleague dick and our
company we're gonna give you a little
introduction and what what is Apache air
flow how can you use it and after that
we're gonna jump right in the hands-on
to get to get to coding right away and
get some experience with with the tool
so yeah we're I'm axel axel goblet I'm a
data scientist at big data Republic and
my colleague dick is standing in the
corner there he works as a data engineer
at Big Data Republic we are as data
consultancy firm located in new pioneer
and you're attacked so we we do cool
projects around data for various
customers so customers we we work with
it so for example KLM of onstart and a
lot of the big big corporates in the
Netherlands and also where we're hiring
by the way so in case you you like this
stuff just leave it drop us a message or
come over after the talk so we're gonna
learn three things today
first one is what is air flow and why is
it actually useful and when is it useful
how to schedule a machine learning
pipeline using Apache air flow and
lastly how can you customize air flow to
two suited to your needs in case you you
want to do anything that's not possible
with with the standard deployment of air
flow so little you know round before so
who has never heard of air flow before
aside from
stalk okay who has actually worked with
airflow before
okay so quite some France there who has
done something with machine learning
with airflow before okay - there so yeah
you might get a bit bored but we have
some advanced exercises and at the end
as well for you I think for the others
it's gonna be a nice ride so to give you
a little context about the tool in the
previous workshop you built a really
nice machine learning model using deep
learning probably use the tensor flow or
PI towards something for days so assume
you you built this model and it worked
really well and you you want to actually
sell it to someone or use it in a
production setting for example if you
work for government who want to check
which houses they need to take care of
if there's a storm coming and what you
want to do is you want to take this
model and have it make predictions every
month for you such that every month you
can yeah make a plan for the next month
about which which houses might be might
be in danger for example well that that
will be a use case where you could use
Apache airflow to do so so so what is
Apache airflow but airflow is a platform
to programmatically author scheduled and
monitor workflows so it's a whole
mouthful and workflow here means
basically a piece of work or so a
sequence of tasks that need to be
executed in a particular order I'm gonna
put some footage put some examples here
as well after and see how every allows
you to to schedule these workflows so
for example run them once a month or
once a week or every day author them -
yeah
define them actually and say which tasks
need to be executed and to monitor them
so check whether things go right and if
things go wrong also alerts that things
went sideways so you can intervene
directly such
your customers are always happy so let's
do a little example here so one of the
famous examples and one of the main use
cases for air flow is actually ETL we
sent for extract transform and load so
assume you have two api's where you want
to retrieve some data from API a and ap
IB and you want to eventually want to
join these datasets and store them
somewhere else for example to to train a
super cool the machine learning model on
then this will be a workflow you would
have to get data from a PA API a get
data from API B you could do this in
parallel because they do not depend on
each other and once both of these
datasets are yeah at your service you
can eventually join them and they store
them in in their joint format another
example would be a machine learning
batch inference but that's also we're
going to do today where it's something
you did in the previous workshop you pre
process some data probably and you train
to a machine learning model and later
you want to use this model to actually
make predictions for this
so you want to pre process some
unlabeled data that you have no no
labels of yet and you want to combine
them with your training model to
actually predict these unlabeled
examples and act upon the predictions so
yeah we can do this with air flow but
probably also yeah some other ways to do
it we could use something like a windows
task scheduler it allows you to run a
program every every day or whenever you
start your computer because use cron
it's like windows task scheduler but
then for Linux but yeah they don't have
nice features like like air flow house
and I'm gonna show you three of the
features that I really like about air
flow but in the hands-on you will
actually
much of the other features that are
included so one of the really cool
features of airflow is that all your
configuration is actually Python code so
it's yeah familiar to all people that do
things with data nowadays because
everything around data is usually in
Python and that she allows you to create
dynamic workflows so for example if you
don't want to talk to two api's like in
the previous example but want to talk to
a hundred there you can just loop over a
list and create a workflow that works
over a hundred api's instead of writing
a hundred of these these blocks like you
would have to do with Windows Start
scheduler
it's a manages connections for you
because air flow is a tool that's
originated as a ETL tool so it allows
you to easily connect with all sorts of
external systems so all the big cloud
providers big big and small databases
they're all included in air flow and you
can easily yeah combine them and get
data from them or sensor data there and
it also allows you to safely store these
credentials you don't want to put your
credentials right in the code because
then if someone reaches your code base
you can just hack your data believing
that that wouldn't be very nice and
maybe it's it's a distributed system so
it allows you to run many patna tasks in
parallel as we saw for example with the
two API cases where yeah you don't have
to wait for the first block to finish
before you can start the second one like
you would have to do in a normal script
but you can run them in parallel and
also because it's distributed we can
choose where to run tasks so we could
run very large tasks for example at our
set this dot process gigabytes of data
we could run it on different nodes or
even on different systems which makes
the whole workflow much more efficient
so a bit about the architecture of
airflow
airflow consists of a few services that
are run in parallel actually and they're
combined by a shared layer of storage
and then this layer of storage to store
your workflows so the definitions you
you create it about what work you want
to be executed some locks about yeah
what happens in these workflows and did
things crash or did they successfully
run and there's some metadata so what
what workers have run and when and what
workers are planned to be run in the
future then the heart of airflow is disk
a jeweler the scheduler basically scans
all your workflows over and over again
and Europe just pieces of Python code
and he checks which workflows need to be
run so if you have a workflow that has
to be run once week on Monday and it is
Monday then the scheduler says oh wait
there it's a work from test tool to run
on Monday I haven't started it yet so a
better hurry up and and get this
workflow started now so if it takes some
more time to schedule make sure that
eventually all your work flows that
should have been run will will be run
now then is scheduler he he chooses
which workflows need to be run and he
distributes this work over an array of
workers so this could be a single
machine it could be actually the same
machine as a scheduler which in your
case for the hands-on will be the case
but it could also be a cluster of nodes
where true to a queue for example the
scheduler can distribute this work and
then each of these workers will pick up
a task and yeah execute it and these
workers are the pieces of software that
actually communicate with these external
systems so they retrieve the connection
information we talked about before and
there they're able to to talk to
external systems so they could get data
from different API or they could
got data from a database to eventually
train a machine learning model with and
to to monitor all of this there is a
last part this is a web server and the
web server is well the gate between many
user us and an airflow so provides us
with a dashboard to actually see the
status of all our different workflows
which have finished we which have failed
and the logs of them so that we can can
monitor them and debug them if that's
necessary so what we are going to do in
this hands-on is we provide all this for
you so you don't have to set up anything
yourself we set up the system in the AWS
cloud for you so everyone gets its own
own instance of airflow and we also
added a jupiter notebook server to it
such that you can write your code and
your workflows in this jupiter notebook
and yeah put it in this shared storage
and it will get ya imported into airflow
automatically them so yeah let's let's
jump into the practical right away the
all the exercises are explained in there
and yeah it should be kind of
self-explanatory if there are questions
we yeah we are around and I love
question about the same topic I'm also
going to add to publicly answer these
questions so what what we're going to do
we're gonna give you a piece of paper
and there is a address and the user and
the password on there so you're going to
go to that address and go to slash user
slash Jupiter don't forget to not put a
trailing slash
because as it will not find the thing
does around good not correctly and in
there there will be a note book called
workshop daughter I PI Y and B and it's
from there you can just start reading
and
right away okay so yeah the the workshop
will end in in a few minutes after that
the all the resources you're using now
they will be destroyed so you won't be
able to actually do the workshop after
the after in about five minutes what we
will do is next week we will share these
slides and the the notebook with you
through troweling then page so yeah
don't get to do follow us there and yeah
you can try to replicate it yourself on
on your own machine so yeah Lynden is
big data are republics to be easily
found and big data in one word which is
quite fun I don't know why